welcome everybody back to this afternoon
or uh
evening session this topic will be
see randomness and uh lower bounds
i would like to ask all the speakers to
make sure to stay within their allotted
eight minutes
and and also try to um
a students if they have a quick question
to ask it at the
end of the talk if they have a question
upload is going to have a longer answer
maybe hold it until the end of the
session where we are going to have time
for a
longer discussion so we start
this session with a talk on
sum of square lower bounds using high
dimensional expanders and
madura is going to give the talk please
can you hear me okay hi
welcome everyone to the virtual talk and
i'll be talking about
uh some connections between uh sum of
squares hierarchy and
certain pseudorandom objects called high
dimensional expanders uh this is joint
work quickly
you also
so high dimensional expanders are the
notions of expanding hypergraphs there
are actually quite a few different
definitions of
what it means to be an expanded
hypergraph motivated by combinatorial
spectral and topological considerations
we won't go into the precise definitions
during the talk except
i should say that there are explicit
constructions given by lebowski samuels
and vishnu
of objects which satisfy many of these
definitions and then these are the ones
that we will use
here and although this is a new area
high dimensional expanders have already
found
a huge number of applications to
uh many different uh
areas in theoretical computer science
and today i'm in particular going to
talk about
their application to constructing hard
instances for certain optimization
problems
the specific optimization problem i'll
be interested in is
3xor which is just a
system of linear equations over f2 so
suppose you are given a system of m
linear equations in n variables
each equation having three variables
over f two and the goal is to find an
assignment to the variable satisfying as
many constraints as possible
and we can also think of it as
being an instance being specified by
a collection of three tuples scripty
which form the left hand side of all the
equations
and a function beta
from this collection script t to f 2 or
0 1 which forms the right hand side of
all these equations so
the instance is specified by a
collection of left hand sides and a
connection of left right hand sides
uh the optimization algorithm we will
consider
for this is something called the sum of
squares hierarchy which is actually a
family of algorithms it's a
it gives semi-definite programming
relaxations for
combinatorial and even continuous
optimization problems
can be thought of as a computational
model in particular for constraint
satisfaction problems if you think of
the hierarchy comes in levels and if you
think of the th level it can be solved
in time into the order t
the specific relaxation will not be as
relevant during the talk but
uh just in case you want to see this is
the relaxation for three xor given by
the sum of squares hierarchy the thing i
would like to note is
uh it's parameterized by this
parameter t and then there is a
unit vector for every subset of the
variables of size at most t and then
this is what defines the hierarchies and
you can think of it as kind of
an algorithm which does all kinds of
local reasoning up to a locality of size
t
but it also does the spectral things
and one aspect that i want to focus on
is that
the many known kind of lower bounds for
this family of algorithms or this
computation model also many upper bounds
but the lower bounds in particular
rely on random instances in one way or
another i mean either you
have a random instance or you start from
random instant do some reduction on top
of it etc
and our goal is to construct explicit
instances
and in particular the result i want to
compare against is this it's known that
if you look at a random three xr formula
choose the left hand sides and right
hand sides both at random sufficient
number of constraints
then the instance is not satisfiable
and in fact is far from satisfiable no
assignment satisfies more than 51
percent of the constraints on the other
hand the sos hierarchy
thinks it's completely satisfiable and
fails to even refute it which means just
prove that
sort of uh
there can be an assignment which can
satisfy all constraints as far as the
sos hierarchy is
concerned and in our work we
kind of give an instance which is
constructable in deterministic
polynomial time
but is weaker in certain senses so first
these instances if you think of this
number mu
is say 0.1 then what we essentially say
is that there are instances which
no assignment satisfies more than 90 of
the constraints
and sos still fails to refute it so the
sos hierarchy still thinks that the
instance is completely satisfiable
but for known random instances this can
be proved even for linear number of
levels or omega n levels of sos
hierarchy
here we can only prove it for square
root log n levels
a couple of comments about the result so
to some extent this issue of 1 minus mu
or 90
versus 51 percent can be sort of
handled in particular combining with
known reductions
and inside the sos hierarchy one can
show that
there are explicit instances in which
the soundness is half plus epsilon so no
assignment satisfies more than half plus
epsilon fraction sos thinks
uh almost all constraints are
satisfiable or one minus delta though
not quite one
and you can also obtain gaps or explicit
instances for many other problems using
reductions
to the best of our knowledge this is the
first explicit integrality gap
construction i should say that if you
are just interested in distinction
between satisfiable and unsatisfiable
there are things called cythin
tautologies which are essentially
systems of xor equations which
is an unsatisfiable system sos thinks
it's satisfiable the construction is
explicit but
there is no gap it's it's kind of almost
satisfiable if you just kind of delete
one equation the system becomes
satisfiable
and don't quite have a gap between
soundness and completeness
another interesting thing is i mean the
instances are not just explicit they
have a nice structure
in particular they're based on these
high dimensional expanders and in this
sense they offer maybe a subtle contrast
or even
maybe apparent contradiction to known
algorithmic results
in particular it's known that for three
xor instances on high dimensional
expanders um
constant number of levels of sos can
obtain arbitrarily good
one plus epsilon approximation and here
i'm telling you that
three xor instances again on high
dimensional expanders that are
hard for square root login levels of sos
to the best of my knowledge both these
results are correct it's a different
definition of
on or what it means for an instance to
be on a high dimensional expander
and let me just illustrate this a little
bit and also to give the construction
so just to do this think of a
hyper graph as a
as as a like we will think of a
simplicial complex which is just a fancy
word for a down
uh for a downward closed hypergraph so
we'll think of collections of three
tuples two tuples
one tuples and sort of subsets of any
three tuple are also contained and we'll
just call them edges vertices and
triangles and
if you think of a three xr instance
with the variables corresponding to the
vertices of a triangle and constraints
corresponding to triangles
and if you have such a structure sitting
on a high dimensional expander then
it's known to be easy if your high
dimensional expander is a good one
on the other hand the instance we
construct
a triangle also has three vertices and
three edges so
if you think of your variables as
sitting on the edges of
each triangle and kind of a three
uniform hyper graph let's say
and if this is a specific
simplicial complex or expanding hyper
graph in particular the ramanujan
complex by luboski samuels and vishne
then we can show that the instance is
actually hard
okay and i won't go into the proof here
too much except to say that
in proof complexity the such things use
kind of expansion of the formula and
here they are replaced by some sort of
topological expansion properties of
these complexes terms of open questions
it's kind of a subtle contrast between
this
vertex or edge variable constructions it
will be good to understand it more
we can stop at square root log n but
it's not clear if that's necessary and
other applications would be good too
good thank you
i'll ask the next speaker to start setup
and
meanwhile if there is any quick question
for maduro we have time for that
salirun has a question
i may be misremembering but i vaguely
recall this sort of distinction between
putting
the variables on edges versus vertices
maybe came up in
in the context of coding and kind of
expander codes versus ldpc codes if i
is there any connection there to
kind of what's happening in what you're
doing or
just superficial similarity
um
i mean okay i can give a slightly longer
speculative answer so maybe we can talk
about it after
the session but yeah let's do that
okay okay that sounds like
a question that deserves a longer answer
okay so for now thanks manure and uh our
next speaker
uh will tell us about uh lower bounds
for uh
turing machines derived from uh
multiplayer
repetition uh hello everyone
so i'm going to be uh can you hear me
yes we do okay so hi everyone
i'm going to be talking about block
rigidity multiplayer parallel repetition
and lower bound for turing machines this
is joint work with
ranraz at princeton university
so our main result is the following we
show that a strong multiplayer parallel
repetition theorem
will imply the existence of something we
call explicit block rigid functions
which will further imply super linear
load bonds for turing machines
with advice first i'll start by talking
about
tiering machines turing machines are the
standard model of computation
used to define complexity classes lower
ones for turing machines
have been long known by the time
hierarchy theorem
paul papenzer simeridian trotter also
showed a separation between
non-deterministic and deterministic
linear time for multi-tape turing
machines
but no such results are known in the
non-uniform setting
the model we are interested in is the
following we'll consider deterministic
multi-type turing machines
that compute multi-output functions so
what i mean by that is that we'll assume
that the tiering machines have separate
input and output tapes and at the end of
computation the machine will write
the entire output on the output tape and
then hold
we'll also allow the machines to be
non-uniform
that means that the machines are allowed
in advice string
which is a function of only the input
length and is written on a
separate advice tape at the beginning of
computation
our main result is the following let t
be
any function that is super linear then
assuming what we call the main
conjecture there exists a function
f such that f maps n bit inputs to
outputs that are of at most n bits the
function f is computable by
deterministic multi-tape turing machines
in
time t but the function f is not
computable by any multi-tape
deterministic turing machine
in linear time and that takes advice
next i will talk about block rigidity
and what our main conjecture is
so in my opinion the definition of block
rigidity is like the main technical
contribution of this paper
we'll be considering functions that take
n times k bits as inputs and
that output n times k bits we say that
such a function is r comma s block rigid
if the following holds so what we want
to say that it is not possible to find a
large set of inputs x
of 0 1 to the n k over which each output
block of the function can be written as
a function
of a small number of blocks of input
variables
so the formula definition is the
following we require that for
every subset x of inputs of size at
least
2 to the nk minus r and suppose we
define subsets s 1 to s k
of 1 to k so basically these will index
the blocks
which will be used to write the output
blocks as functions of the input blocks
so we want these subsets to be of size
at most s
and functions g1 to gk so the ih
bit if function gi will take us input
the blocks of the input that are indexed
by si and we require that
gi outputs the ith
block of output of f x and we want to
say that for any
large enough set this is not possible if
f is rigid
in the case n is equal to one we call
such functions r commas rigid functions
and not block wizard so the word rigid
comes from relation to valiant's notion
of
rigid matrices more details about this
are in the long talk
so i'd say one thing uh the notion of
rigid matrices was
introduced by value into showing lower
bounds against
logarithmic depth and linear size
arithmetic circuits
the notion of rigid functions which
corresponds to the case n
is equal to 1 corresponds so essentially
the same proof gives lower bounds
against
general boolean circuits
for our lower bounds we'll mostly be
interested in the case
when k is just slightly super constant
and r comma s
are omega of nk and omega k so this
corresponds to very strong block
rigidity
the main conjecture is the following so
suppose
f which takes in k bits as input and k
bits of
output and which is an omega k comma
omega k 3
function so almost strongly suppose f is
a random function so random functions
satisfy
such a property with very high
probability
then we conjecture that the function f
to the n
which is from 0 1 to the n k to 0 1 to
the n k
is n omega n k comma omega of k block
rigid function
which is the domain we were interested
in so what what is the function f to the
n
so basically the idea is to think of the
input as a k
cross n matrix and we just want to apply
f to each of the columns which is of
size k
and then the new matrix is the output
i would like to mention the connection
between this and multiplayer parallel
repetition
if you do not know what multiplier
parallel repetition is i would recommend
you to watch the longer talk so i'll
just state the results here
so we show that a strong parallel
repetition theorem
for a certain class of multiplayer games
implies the main conjecture
our class of multiplayer games satisfy a
very special property
which is the following for every random
string of the verifier
there is a unique correct answer for
each of the players so we refer to such
games as independent games
we believe that this strong condition
may allow us to prove
very strong parallel repetition on such
class of games
despite very less known bounds on
multiplayer parallel repetition
at the end i would like to mention some
other directions the first is can we
prove
strong block rigidity for other
functions this would imply super linear
lower bounds
against tiering machines with advice for
those functions
some candidates are the following the
first is matrix transpose
so given an n cross n matrix a in row
major order
we want to output its transpose in row
major order
this is basically a problem on permuting
the input in a certain
form the second problem is matrix
product
so given to n cross in matrix is a and b
we want to output the product matrix a
times b block residue for these
functions translates to
answering very simple combinatorial
problems i would like to mention
the problem for matrix transpose here
it basically leads to the following
combinatorial question
what is the size of a largest family of
n cross and matrices
that satisfy the following what we want
is that in this family for every matrix
in this family
the columns of the matrices can be
written as a function of a small number
of rows of the matrices
so formally we want to find subsets s1
to sm of the rows
each of size n over 100 this n over 100
can be replaced by any small constant
times
n and functions g1 to gn which take in
these rows indexed by s1 to sn and
they output the jth column so the formal
definition is stated
we conjected that the size of such a
largest family is at most
the density of such a largest family is
at most two to the minus omega
n square this would imply that the
matrix transpose
problem cannot be computed by multi-tape
deterministic
turing machines that take advice
so i'll end with this open problem thank
you
thank you very much kunal um
is there any quick question for kunal
about his talk
uh i might be missing something about uh
right so strong parallel repetition does
not
hold for two player games so what why
are you
hopeful that it would work for modi yeah
so but
the class of games we described so i
said they satisfy this very special
property
so we believe that the class of games
that satisfy this very special property
it
might be possible to prove strong
parallel repetition and do you know if
it works for
for uh two player games like for this
subclass
okay so the thing is that if we have
games that have k players the kind of
bound we want on the end parallel
repetition is something like 2 to the
minus k times n
some constant times k times n and
the class we are looking at it is very
easy to prove bounds
like 2 to the minus omega n
so the question itself becomes
interesting when the number of players
is also growing within
listen thank you
thanks again so i'll ask the next
speaker to
set up for the talk
generators for unbounded with
permutation branching problems
go ahead with them thanks um
yeah so i'm uh presenting joint work
with ted pine
and salil vadon about pseudorandom
generators
a pseudorandom generator is a function
that stretches a
short truly random seed out to a long
pseudorandom string
and the way we make this precise is we
consider some class of test functions f
and the requirement is that for every
function in this class
if you look at the acceptance
probability of f on a pseudorandom input
versus the acceptance probability of f
on a truly random input those two
acceptance probabilities should be
within epsilon of each other so epsilon
is the error of the pseudorandom
generator
and the test functions that we're going
to be looking at are
based on ordered branching programs so
this is a simple model of computation
where we have some directed layered
graph
so there are n plus one layers of
vertices
and each vertex has two outgoing edges
pointing at the next layer of vertices
and the two outgoing edges are labeled
zero and one
a program like this can read an input
string as follows you start at
the designated start vertex in the first
layer and then you read the input string
from left to right one bit at a time
to decide which outgoing edges to take
from each vertex
so in this way you walk through this
directed graph and arrive at some vertex
in the final layer
there's one vertex in the final layer
that's the designated accept vertex of
the program
and the program accepts or rejects the
input depending on whether it arrives at
that except vertex
so in this way a program like this
computes some boolean function
f on n bits one of the most important
parameters of a
branching program like this is the width
of the program which is the number of
vertices per layer
the width measures the space complexity
of this computational process
the most important case is width and
length and
ordered branching programs when the
width is equal to the length
there's a simple argument based on the
probabilistic method that shows that
there exists a pseudorandom generator
for width and length and ordered
branching programs with seed length log
n over epsilon
and we would really like to design
explicit pseudorandom generators with
the same seed length
that would have some uh nice
consequences one of which would be this
deer randomization result it would imply
l
equals bpl so the deer randomization of
space bounded computation
unfortunately so far the best explicit
constructions are not as good as the
best as
as what the probabilistic method gives
in fact the best explicit pseudorandom
generator for width and
length and ordered branching programs uh
is nissan pseudorandom generator from 30
years ago which has seed length like log
squared n
plus log n times log one over epsilon
and so because it's it's been so long
you know there have been so many decades
without uh
improvements on nissan's generator for
this for the general case
researchers have looked at more
restricted classes of branching programs
to try to make progress
one example of this of a more restricted
class is what are called
permutation branching programs so this
is where we add this extra assumption
that says in each layer uh if you look
at just the edges labeled zero
they form a matching and if you look at
just the edges labeled one
they also form a matching or in other
words a permutation on the states
a permutation on these states of the
branching program
so this this condition means that we're
considering some notion of like
reversible computation like you can you
can recover
you know you can run run the computation
backward
and in particular it implies that the
program is regular meaning that each
vertex
has two incoming edges
and so there's been a lot of research on
explicit pseudorandom generators for
permutation branching programs and for
regular branching programs
uh and at this point uh we do have
explicit pseudorandum generators for
constant width permutation branching
programs
uh with with a better seed length
seedling log n times log
one over epsilon um
unfortunately though for the larger
width case like the most important case
the width
n case uh prior to our work the best
pseudorandom generator was still nissan
pseudorandom generator even even for the
for permutation branching programs
uh so that's where we come in uh we were
looking at wider permutation branching
programs
and we actually said you know let's go
ahead and skip past uh
polynomial with and let's go all the way
to unbounded width
so at this point you know when we're
talking about unbounded width branching
programs
this is no longer about the deer
randomization of space bounded
computation because we don't have a
bound on space anymore instead it's like
deer randomization of
of some model of reversible computation
this permutation condition
um so what we prove uh our theorem says
that there is an explicit pseudo-random
generator for
unbounded width permutation branching
programs with seed length roughly log n
times log one over epsilon so it's
roughly the same seed length that was
previously known
for the constant width case uh and and
here we have this seed length with
absolutely no dependence on width
whatsoever
the cedar random generator itself uh is
not new it's the inw generator for those
of you who know what that is impoliato
nissan viggerson generator
uh so it's the same construction as ever
but it's it's a
it's a different analysis
uh there is one crucial assumption that
i really want to highlight
uh which is is that in our model of
permutation branching program
we only allow a single vertex in the
final layer to be the designated
accepting vertex maybe sounds you know
in some cases that's sort of a
technicality but in this case it really
makes all the difference in this this is
this is a crucial assumption it's a big
caveat
um so the only previous result about
this sort of
strange unconventional model uh was by
day who
who gave a seed length bound of log
squared n plus log n times log one over
epsilon so it's like the same as you
know nissan's generator for the
polynomial with case but de showed it
for the unbounded width case
so to prove uh our theorem uh some of
the concepts that we use
are the concept of the de-randomized
square by rosenman and vadon
and then this this recent notion of unit
circle approximation which was
introduced at fox this past year by
ahmadinejad kiln
kellner murtaugh peebles sidford and
vadon and we really rely
very heavily on on their results and
their analysis of this this unit circle
approximation
so for context uh let me tell you know
those of you who maybe don't work on
pseudorandom generators tell you a
little bit about how how these sorts of
problems usually go
um what we're used to in the
pseudorandom generators world
is we're used to you know we're trying
to design pseudorandom generators for
some class and first we can just you do
a simple probabilistic method argument
to show that there exists some
pseudorandom generator with with a great
seed length maybe log in over epsilon
and and typically it's really easy to
prove a matching lower bound you know
show that that's the optimal seed length
uh and so that the main challenge in the
usual case the main challenge is to
devise an explicit construction
that matches this probabilistic argument
but this uh the model that we're
studying this unbounded width
permutation branching program model is
is a bit strange and unconventional
and this whole story provably breaks
down
so let me explain what i mean uh so you
could consider
sampling some generator uniformly at
random from all functions mapping s bits
to n bits
and then we prove that unless the seed
length is really high like close to n
uh with high probability g fails to be a
pseudorandom generator for unbounded
width permutation branching programs
okay so this is a case where an explicit
construction you know
the inw c drain of generator under our
analysis
is much much much better than a randomly
chosen generator
right the randomly chosen generator
would need near linear seed length
uh the proof of this is is pretty
elementary um the main step is just
identifying a suitable like uh hard
family of functions that can be computed
by
exponent permutation branching programs
uh so because you know the the the
probabilistic method
uh fails to guide us it's not a reliable
guide for this model and telling us
about pseudorandom generators
uh this sort of calls into question you
know what is the optimal seed length for
the
for this model um and
it turns out uh we proved that uh any
pseudorandom generator for unbounded
width permutation branching programs
must have seed length at least roughly
log n times log one over epsilon
so this you know this lower bound
basically matches our upper bound
uh regarding the inw generator and so it
means that in this setting the setting
of unbounded width
branching programs permutation branching
programs the inw generator is near
optimal
um and so this is this is strange it's
different than what we're used to
you know usually for pseudorandom
generators problems what we expect is
that the optimal seed length should be
something plus
log one over epsilon uh but this is a
strange case where the optimal seed
length
is log n times log one over epsilon
so some of the tools we use to prove
this are are some tools from matching
theory
and some tools from information theory
okay so just just to conclude um this
you know we studied this unconventional
model of permutation branching programs
with no bound whatsoever on the width
of the program and i think
that this model pushes back against uh
some of the standard intuitions that
we're used to when it comes to
pseudorandomness and de-randomization
um for that reason uh i would suggest
that it might be useful to have
this model and and these results in the
back of your head as
as potentially counter examples uh you
know to any conjectures you might you
might
start formulating about about
pseudorandom generators
and uh there are some open questions you
know we give several in the paper uh
that are about like extending this work
to uh even more general cases um
and i'd be happy to talk about them uh
thanks for listening
thank you uh so actually william's talk
around a little bit
late so we suggest to skip directly to
the
next talk so even if you have short
questions for william holden
until then uh william please stop
uh sharing the screen so the next
speaker can
[Music]
uh share the screen and next talks will
be on
notions of pseudoentropy
for very limited classes of statistical
tests
and whether they are equivalent or not
and the speaker i guess is going to be
some yeah uh can you hear me alright
yes go ahead so okay great yeah so uh
thanks for the opportunity to share this
um my name's sam
um and this is uh based off of joint
work with
my advisor russell and uh yeah so i'll
talk about
um so different notions of computational
entropy
as well as the dense model theorem
so uh the starting point for this
project is is a statement called the
dense model theorem
and this is a result in pseudoranimus uh
with applications and kind of a
surprising uh diversity of areas so
so the first application was in additive
number theory
and uh this was due excuse me due to uh
greentown dow ziegler um and
they were interested in using it to uh
to
you know solve a number theory problem
they wanted to find uh arithmetic
progressions in the prime numbers
and they use this uh you know to prove
the green tau theorem which is
uh you know kind of a landmark of the
past uh
20 years in mathematics
another interesting application which
doesn't have anything to do with number
theory
is in differential privacy so uh miranav
at all they were able to use the dense
model theorem to
to give relationships between different
computational definitions of
differential privacy
okay so um so let's work kind of towards
uh
towards stating the theorem so so we
basically start with a
set s over a finite universe u and we
and we think of the set as being small
okay and the in the dense model theorem
will give us basically sufficient
conditions for s
to uh like look like it's dense
according to some class of tests
okay and the test class uh will consist
of uh functions which are kind of uh
which have bounded range between zero
and one okay and like another way of
saying looking dense
uh is also saying that maybe s is a high
computational entropy
okay um so to be more formal
we're looking specifically for um an s
with for an s that has such that has an
m
uh so that m is delta den so it has
measure at least delta or the uniform
distribution on u
and we also would like it to be uh
indistinguishable from s
so so we'll say it's like an epsilon
model with respect to tests
f and this is just the standard notion
of indistinguishability
okay um so the point is is that m is
actually dense
uh so we could kind of use uh nice
properties have done sets
uh so uh you know uh
to to reason about us okay so so now
we'll talk about the sufficient
condition
so so the sufficient conditions are
actually weaker computational entropy
conditions okay
so so the the way we uh
define or like the conclusion of the
dense model theorem says that
s has a delta dense epsilon model if it
satisfies the sufficient conditions
but there are other kind of reasonable
ways to try to to define
uh what it means to look dense in the
first place okay
so in this sense the dense model theorem
will basically give us like an upgrade
will kind of take a weaker notion or a
set that satisfies a weaker notion of
computational entropy and it will
tell us it will give us it will be able
to
give us a stronger notion of
computational entropy that satisfies
okay
so uh so basically we're going to have
these parameters
so the entropy conditions will be with
respect to
uh to parameters f prime and epsilon
prime where
f prime is like a new test class based
off of f and we just define it in terms
of a function g
so we just take like any k elements of f
and compose it with g and two kind of
important examples for us
are uh like a product
and the majority of of cape it's okay
um okay and it turns out basically that
there are there are two
weaker notions of of computational
entropy which suffice
uh you know to obtain the conclusion um
the first and this is the first one that
appeared uh
so i'm not going to define it formally
but but but uh
it just says that the set s is dense
inside of a pseudorandom set
okay and this was due to tau zigler and
gowers also gave another proof of it um
and the uh the
the parameters in order uh in order for
this to be
true we need to take epsilon prime to be
like exponentially small in the other
parameters
but we can take f prime to be like a
product of
uh of functions in f and so it'll be a
product of
k functions in f but i'm going to kind
of not really care about k
we can just think of it as like
polynomial in like one in epsilon
and one in delta okay um
and i'll mention like so it's kind of
important that f prime
is just a product because uh
you know it's not clear if they would
have been able to establish kind of the
pseudo-randomness conditions they needed
if it was more complicated than that
okay
so the second definition or the second a
sufficient condition
in uh which uh originally burdened
rheingold travis and dulciani have done
um it uh it is
it kind of enjoys a better dependence
for epsilon prime so now some prime can
be
just some polynomial in epsilon delta
but f prime
uh needs to now be kind of a majority of
uh of elements in f
okay and the second condition uh i'll
just
say so to one name for it is metric
pseudoentropy but you can just
understand it to mean
that like every f can be fooled by some
model
which depends on the function so so
specifically like
um you know so i give you an f and
you get to design an m which is supposed
to be indistinguishable from
s with by f okay
so we were interested just in
understanding um
you know if the kind of tension between
epsilon prime
and f prime is necessary here so so like
we can see that like if we want to take
epsilon prime to be larger like in the
second
application then we need to take f prime
to be more complicated
um and if we want f prime to be simpler
it seems like we need to take epsilon
prime to be smaller okay
so uh we're able to basically show
that's true in a couple of different um
we're able to show that this tension is
kind of inherent in a couple of
different cases so kind of informally we
can show that either epsilon prime is
going to be tiny
or f prime is going to be complicated in
some way okay
so uh more specifically like we can show
that the dense model theorem will be
false
in in ac 0 so constant depth circuits
starting from either of the sufficient
conditions if we assume epsilon prime is
like polynomial
okay and we can also show that the
sufficient conditions themselves are an
equivalent
with respect to a couple of different uh
test classes like ac zero low degree
polynomials and kind of a more
and there's kind of a more general
condition on the test class we can get
uh by using a result of schulte
viola okay um
okay so that's so that's basically all i
wanted to say about the result um
and i'll say a couple of final notes
um so first uh
by kind of a reduction of impaculatsu
these results
imply uh that the hardcore lemma uh from
circuit complexity can also fail
so previously uh this was
kind of known like so so lutze lu tsai
and
wu showed that like black box proofs of
the hardcore lemma
can be used in some sense to compute
majority but this is kind of the first
explicit example
uh at least that russell and i are aware
of um
where the hardcore limb is actually just
false okay
and then i'll i'll mention another
question which
may appear slightly unrelated um but so
um so this is kind of in the context of
de-randomization where we where we want
to
construct pseudorandom generators and an
interesting idea
for doing that is uh which is uh
which appeared in sudan travis and vadon
is to basically
generate a pseudo-entropy in some sense
and then extract randomness from them
okay
um so the problem with this is that we
would actually need to
kind of we need kind of the strongest
notion of pseudoentropy this idea of
having a dense model in order to do the
extraction
and and now we know that kind of doing
the conversion from the weaker notion of
the stronger notion requires majority
so the question is kind of like could
this framework work in a circuit class
below majority so say for example like
ac 0
with parity gates okay and this is kind
of in contrast to
chaltilla viola who showed kind of
another way of constructing pseudorandom
generators
uh uh or another kind of step in
constructing pseudorandom generators
requires majority which is
hardened simplification um
okay and uh and that's it and and thanks
for listening
thank you um is there any
uh quick question for some
uh yes a little go ahead okay this time
i'll actually ask a quick question
um can you just uh uh say a little bit
more about what you mean
with the phrase can fail you mean you
give a function you give vote
yeah we give a distribution which
satisfies
the uh the sufficient condition and
doesn't satisfy the conclusion yeah
so it's just false yeah great thanks
thanks again so stop sharing the screen
so the next speaker
can set up and our next talk will be
on uh getting a cubic formula lower
bound for
an explicit function in ac 0.
who is giving the talk hi
hi yes so i'm giving the talk oh yeah
we're sorry
please go ahead i'll answer thank you
so this is uh joint work with uh yuval
phil moose and norma here
um right
so we are talking about wooden functions
in this talk
and the model of computation is the
morgan formulas these are binary trees
we've
orn and gates and we have variables
authentication
at the bottom and two complexity
measures that we care about
about regarding formulas are the size
and the depth
so we denote by l of f the minimum
number of
leaves in any formula computing the
boolean function f
note that there might be several
formulas computing the same function f
and similarly we denote by depth of f or
d of f
the minimal depth of formal computing f
and depth uh
is motivated because it really captures
the parallel time
the time that it takes the value of the
you know this formula to compute the
output
if you think of all these things as
working in parallel then the depth is
really
the time it takes values to propagate
from leaves to root
right and it turns out that studying
depth and selling
size is essentially the same because of
this beautiful connection
due to shapira that show that the
optimal depth up to constant is
log the optimal size
okay so this brings us to the main
open question in this in this
field of study the p versus nc one
question
um does every language in p that can be
solved in polynomial time
can be stored in logarithmic depth or in
other words in logarithmic part of time
this is too good to be true we don't
believe this to be the case but we don't
know that
this is false equivalently we can ask
whether everything in p can be computed
by polynomial size formulas
so as i said there's like a big gap
between what we believe and what we can
prove
we believe that some problems in p
require exponential
formula size or linear depth these are
problems that
are sort of intuitively are inherently
uh sequential and cannot
benefit from running it in parallel
however we don't know how to prove that
and the best that we can prove is that
some problems require
inc and cube formula size and we will
see
the specific uh problems that require
n-cube formula size and we will see
more problems that we uh show in this
work that requires uh for n cube formal
size as well
okay a second uh interesting question
that is motivating by the p
versus nc one question is this question
about composition
let's say that we have two functions f
and g and we take their composition
what do i mean by that so these are
boolean functions so to take the
composition i need to take several
copies of g
i'm fitting each copy with a distinct
set of variables and then i'm taking all
the outputs and feed it into f
so a natural question is what's the
formal size of this composed function
and quite obvious from the picture the
formal size of the composition is at
most the formal size of f times the
formal size of g
we just take the formula for f and
replace that relief with the formula for
g
and the question is whether or not this
is type this was
posed in the this semi seminal paper by
a karchmer razer and figures on and
these conjectures that indeed this is
tied moreover they showed that if
this conjecture is correct then they
came up with an explicit function that
requires
a super polynomial formula size meaning
that they showed how giving this
conjecture you can separate p from and
c1
i want to mention that a notable special
case of this conjecture is when
g is just the party function and
it is known that this special case is
correct and based on that we can get the
enqueue blower bond
okay so let me tell you a little bit
more about this mq log bar
the essential properties that is used in
this lower bound is the shrinkage of
formulas under random restrictions let
me give you first an example so
here's the formula from the first slide
and now let's fix
x1 to be the constant zero
this makes these two leaves a zero and a
one
but now we notice that we can actually
simplify this formula further
because 0 and something is 0 and 1 and
x3 is x3
so we can simplify it further to this
thing and even further to just
one leaf so we see that the formula of
size 4 with 4 leaves
became a formula of size 1 after a
restriction
and this is not a coincidence it turns
out that any formula
shrinks under random restriction that
fixes most of the variables
and the factor of shrinkage is roughly n
squared
so you take any large tree and you fix
most of its variables and you get a tree
which is of size
smaller by a factor of n squared on the
other hand
andreiev came up with an explicit
function such that after shrinkage the
formula size
should be at least n which means that
before shrinkage the formula
size should be at least n cubed in other
words in order to show that the tree is
large you show that it shrinks by a
significant factor
and that it is not that small afterwards
okay so andreev construction is the
following
function it's actually a special case of
composition
you take a composition of some hard
function f0
that is on a few bits log n
many bits and you take this composition
with the parity function over n over log
n bits
if you apply random restriction each of
these parties becomes something like a
dictator
and you are left with something like f
zero uh however
the formation size shrinks by factor s
fence squared so this shows you
the formal size of the original
functions at least n squared bigger than
the size of f zero
which gives you the end cube a lower
bound
in other words this is also an example
that the krw
conjecture holds for for this special
case because the formal size of parity
is indeed
a quadratic
okay so i
proposed one a proof technique to show
formal robots
there's another proof technique okay so
this first proof techniques that i
mentioned is random restriction and this
is a bottom-up
technique we sort of saw what happens to
the leaves and somehow
from the leaves we went up right so so
it seems that like sub-formulas
became smaller formulas and we didn't
really touch the top
part of the formula there's another
approach which is a top-down approach
uh using the uh kw games or karchmere
wigglers and games
this was suggested in this seminal paper
of cartman victor zone
they suggested a rephrasing of this
question of
formula depth in the language of
communication complexity
you can write a game between alice and
bob
alice gets an input x such that f x
equals one and bob gets a y such at f y
equals zero
and the goal is to find a coordinate i
such that
this x is different than y i in terms of
the protocols for this game
correspond you know as the one one horse
ones with formulas for the function
and the size of the protocol tree is the
same as the size of the formula so
this is really the same question in a
different language
and this is really a top-down approach
because naturally when you talk about
communication
you start with the root and you go down
to the
okay so in terms of the top-down
approach are very
uh useful in proving lower bounds in the
monotone setting
and they also seem to be a promising
towards the krw conjecture
and in particular proving intermediate
results towards it
and recently the nora mayor also gave a
new proof
using the language of communication
complexity for the enqueue blower pawn
so it seems that everything that we can
do in the bottom up setting we can also
do in the top down
and this motivates the question are top
down techniques superior to bottom up
techniques
this
problem that we came up with is can you
prove an nq blurb on not
just for any function in p but for a
function that is in
ac 0 which is like constant depth
unbounded fan in circuits
it seems uh on one hand that the
techniques by dinor mayer could be
extended to this regime so we were
hopeful
to prove it using the normal years
framework and we were also certain that
random restriction techniques would not
be able to prove this result
and the reason for that is that random
restrictions
have the property that they make any
function in ac 0
constant with high probability what does
it mean it means that after
the restriction the function is so
simple that i can just compute it by
a constant simply a constant function or
size 0 formula so i cannot really get
anything
at least superficially i cannot get
anything from random restriction
techniques against
functions in ac0 it turns out that our
intuition was false
and we are able to prove these results
using
random restriction techniques but we are
not using the standard
random restrictions but rather random
restrictions that are tailored
to the heart function okay so this is
our main result we've proved nq blur
for function in ac0 the function
is a variant of the andrea function
notice
this is a very similar picture to what
we saw earlier
but i'm replacing the party function
with the activity function
this is necessary since part is not in
ic 0. so i must
replace objectivity and surjectivity is
a
is a well-studied function that can be
computed in ac0 and requires
quadratic formula size
we are able to show that this function
requires like this composed function
requires
cubic size and in particular we showed
that the kw conjecture works
when we compose any function f with the
search activity function i will show you
quite a bit over time okay so this is
just the last slide
can i can just finish my last slide
uh well in a few seconds yes
okay so i just want to mention that our
proof uses
tailor-made random projections um in a
sense that
the the random projections are not uh
independent projections that
pick everything independently at random
but they maintain the structure of the
function
they are tailored to the structure of
the function and on the other hand they
also shrinks the formula and we may
we need to keep a balance between these
two properties which is
uh where most of the analysis goes into
this is inspired by the work of
er rosmann ceridian 10 that did
something similar
to separate depth d from depth d plus
one okay
thank you thank you very much and also
thank you very much to
all the speakers now we have a bit of
time or actually as much time as we want
to have follow-up questions
i would like to start with sally's
question to
madur about can you remind us what was
your
question to uh maduro
oh uh i mean maybe mordor will rephrase
it better than i
asked it so i'll just say sure
if you remember
if i understood correctly you were
asking uh
this sort of relation between edge and
vertex variable version and how it shows
in expander codes versus how it shows up
in here so i mean okay
where it kind of shows up in expander
codes if i understood correctly you may
be referring to like tanner codes or
something where
the vertex is a parity check and edges
are variables
so there i mean one reason to do it is
of course that
you want dimension arguments the number
of vertices is less than the number of
edges but if you do it the other way
around
it's not clear how to prove things are
non-empty
there is some connection though in the
sense that
if you think of triangles they do form
parity checks on
on the set of edges in a high
dimensional expander and
the fact that this gives a nice code is
something that we do use
although here the number of triangles is
actually more than the number of edges
so the triangles are always parity
checks it's just whether the variables
are on edges or vertices
and the fact that this code is even
non-empty
is not so obvious in fact this is
and this is used in proving the
soundness in our construction it's and
then somehow the fact that you can get
these sort of things is the
homological expansion or systolic
expansion property of these
so there is some connection because of
this parity check but
slightly different but this is the
extent to which i understand it right
thanks mother uh thanks for the it's
actually a question for
william about the model of permutation
branching programs
that you work with so i could see that
requiring so that you cannot require
you cannot allow arbitrary final states
to be accepting because otherwise
you could recognize it so an arbitrary
function would be
sort of computable that way
but what if you
at least allow like a constant number of
accepting states would you get something
similar to
the known results for constant with
permutation branching programs
sure yeah good question yeah so um
if you have a program that has a few
accepting states like let's say a
accepting states then you could write
that as a sum of
a many programs each with one accepting
state
um and so what that means is that our
pseudorandom generator does
automatically fool
programs with several accepting states
it's just that the error
grows with the number of accepting
vertices so a constant number of
vertices we can handle fine
but once you get up to like polynomially
many accepting vertices then we're not
getting
any more uh any improvement you know
uh well yeah i mean uh we don't know
what the situation is once you you know
once once you have like polynomially
many accepting vertices
we don't know what uh you know what the
optimal seedling is there a simple
example of a function that
cannot be computed by a permutation
branching program of
unbounded width and one accepting state
yeah that's a good question i mean so i
guess uh
definitely our cedar end of generators
yeah yeah
generator right uh but i that's that's a
really
good question i haven't thought about
whether there's a simple i'm guessing
there's some trivial example but uh good
question i don't know actually
okay but more generically right what's
the intuition what kind of functions can
these things compute
this this kind of branching program what
do they compute
right so i think i think some of the
intuition
is comes from uh like the other example
of like hard functions that we used for
our lower bounds
i think those help to sort of clarify
what these things can do so
uh the the family there is if you
consider
any permutation on zero one to the n
over two
so like any permutation on n over two
bits
um then there is a permutation branching
program that takes as input you know
x comma y and it tests whether
the permutation applied to x equals y
um so that's that's that's the sort of
thing that you can do with
this like you know this vast amount of
width is you can do something like
you know read and remember the entire
first half of the input
and then apply some permutation and
compare it to the second half of the
input
um and if the width
isn't that large then this this model
becomes weaker right
if the if the width isn't very large
yeah i mean if the width is like only
polynomial for example
um then yeah i mean then there are
pseudo right the optimal seed length of
pseudorandom generators
uh gets shorter right if it's only
polynomial width then we're sort of in
this the standard regime where the
probabilistic method works and things
like that so
thank you any uh questions for any of
the speakers
i have another question for william uh
so like the example that you gave as a
very small
uh probability of acceptance do you have
uh so in particular it could be
approximated by like just constant zero
do you have examples where you can show
like that you really
that you can solve it with a very large
width
but you cannot approximate with small
width
uh good question no we have the opposite
we we we showed actually that there
that any of these like you know
exponential width branching programs
can be approximated uh by
a polynomial width branching program uh
but only on one side
um we get lower approximators but not
upper approximators and so what that
means is that um
if we're considering hitting set
generators instead of pseudorandom
generators
then uh the hitting set generator
problem for these unbounded width
programs is just the same as like the
hitting set generator problem for
polynomial with programs and so it's
sort of back into the standard regime
where the probabilistic method works and
stuff like that
but the approximators only go on one
side
do we know that inw cannot be a
pseudonym generator for permutation
branching programs
say for polynomial with right but with
the general
subset of states writing like a
in the end
uh uh no i mean
in fact i would say it seems perfectly
plausible
that the inw generator does fool those
those programs i mean i don't know
good question
okay the next session in the room is
about to start the first talk would be
on the total functions in the
hierarchy and maybe crystals will give
the talk of nature
so if there are no more questions for
our spirits i would take them once more
and close this section
thanks everybody bye yes
ronan if you want to stay on for a
second i think i
might have some thoughts on your last
question
what wasn't there wasn't there a paper
by brody or something
like years ago showing a counter example
for nissan's
generator but there's some instantiation
i don't think it was brody it was one of
our dead's uh students maybe
a master's thesis that are dead
supervised
i don't remember exactly but that was
yeah that was for nissan's generator and
i don't think it was restricted to
permutation
programs i think it's for constant
weight
but i i think maybe for your question
um all right so it depends on what do
you mean by the inw generator but if you
mean the inw
generator where all you assume of the
the auxiliary graphs is that
that you have a bound on the spectral
gap
then i then it may be
possible to uh come up with a
uh a bad example so something along the
lines of i think you can kind of
cook it up that if you're if your
spectral gap
um is lambda then basically
think of these as like doing random
walks on graphs that that that in every
step
um kind of you
each time you you do a a level of inw or
de-randomize square you slow down the
random walk by it like with probability
lambda you stay in place instead of walk
moving
moving forward which so there's some
example for the d randomized square
analysis of spectral gap being being
tight in
in the de-randomized square paper
um and i think it remains tight under
kind of
recursive applications which kind of
says that
i think that implies that if you for
example are using
constant degree expanders or constants
using constant spectral gap um
in uh
you you you you will kind of
mix probably more slowly than than a
truly random
walk and hence be statistically far from
the right distribution and so if you
have an arbitrary subset of except for
it
this is just kind of guessing but i i i
think
um the the answer to your question is
is probably the inw generator if if this
is what you interpret it to be
uh probably can't uh get login over
epsilon
okay so i don't want to get in trouble
because i see that russell is here so i
don't want to interpret
that right i
where people have their crews and their
storm
their capital right i mean
what happened to you
but suppose my invention of the rnw
generator was there
angled with extractors but i'm not with
spectral
yeah if you start allowing that kind of
flexibility i mean
there's there's some point at which um
there's some level of generality at
which
uh
again this is just guessing i think
there's some level of generality in the
phrasing of the inw generator
where if you then choose the graphs that
you use at random
one can do maybe some kind of
probabilistic method argument to
um to argue that it can actually a
construction of that form can actually
work um
i think uh again i'm not a 100 percent
sure of that so i think i think it just
will be sensitive to how general you
allow
the construction to be
yeah do you have in mind i mean you know
a an approach for proving
what you just suggested that you know if
we pick the if we if we use random
graphs
instead of expanders yes yes that's what
i meant by the problem yes exactly
exactly random graphs and you don't
you don't go all the way down to the
level of um bits maybe
um maybe there's some
maybe you don't reveal the entire uh
let's see if i remember correctly
this is a kind of very long time ago
played around
a little bit with with things along
these lines but it's all this is all
just kind of
guessing answers to your question ronan
it's uh
someone someone should actually try to
work it out
yeah thanks it's very
good so is there any hope to use these
techniques uh uh for
standard or if there is such a thing as
like standard uh
permutation branching programs we've
we've fixed with like some fee with
larger than a constant
yes i mean it did already give you know
new results
for you know like the polynomial width
case under this assumption of one
accepting vertex
no so but suppose suppose i don't want
this uh this assumption of one accepting
vertex
right and but i give you a budget of
where right now
i only really want you to do moving
constantly
so it is obvious of these techniques to
raise the base impactful
yeah so i mean yeah i mean if it's like
logarithmic width or something
right then i mean then in particular
there are only logarithmically many
accepting vertices
and so you just pay a factor of log n in
the
in the error of the program and so
so hey maybe it's worth mentioning so if
if we
um so if you
if you take that arbit sort of arbitrary
permutation branching programs
uh with any number of except vertices
and you and you
don't care about having a generator
but are willing to do a um
a non-oblivious um you know estimate
acceptance probabilities that that we
know how to do
um that was
kind of the the previous paper from fox
that
that we build on for the generator
that can do that with um
nearly logarithmic uh in in nearly
logarithmic
space so do what you
would be able to do and and even better
in terms of epsilon
uh than than you would have with a with
an optimal prg and so the
a a question is um
an open question though is whether you
can get that better
handle the many except vertices or get
better dependence on the error
uh in an oblivious like prg
like way
thanks and it's great seeing you guys
likewise yeah yeah you too
all right bye everyone
oh i should introduce ted ted also
co-author
on the paper ted ronnie avishai
ted's an undergrad at harvard nice to
meet you
thank you for all the great comments
yeah it's it's raining it's at 12
30 right after midnight in israel
it doesn't look like it behind you it
looks uh
sunny yeah honey and windy
where is it from so how is this possible
you're not in israel i guess uh no it's
weird
virtual background right and right like
for people who don't know
who don't read hebrew i can reveal where
bishop is
[Laughter]
i used google translate already
[Laughter]
challenge anymore right
yeah elon was asking me if i'm in a spa
i was i was answering him
no i mean right like i could show you
the back of the room but
i'm sitting in this like very small like
kind of basement
with a lot of laundry behind me so i